jamus Winston went against coach's
orders on Sunday's game and I need to
know whose side you're on because
Shannon sharp wants jamus Winston cut
ASAP but his teammate Chris Al is
calling him a real one the saints were
up 41 to 17 against the Falcons and with
a little over a minute to go you'd think
the Saints would just take a knee to end
the game well that was what New Orleans
head coach Dennis Allen instructed but
Winston and the team decided to
disregard the call and fake the kneel
and hand the ball off to Jamal Williams
for a touchdown not so classy right
Dennis Allen was not thrilled after the
game and even had to apologize to
Falcons coach Arthur Smith but Winston
did have an interesting explanation
after the game Williams had yet to score
a touchdown all season and Winston said
that if someone who fights and puts
Blood Sweat and Tears into every game
has an opportunity to get into the end
zone he's going to make it happen for
him and he's going to feel good about
doing it he said do you think Winston
and the Saints made the right call